I think anyone who hasn't experienced
racism shouldn't say anything about it
full stop well Okay cool so I agree
quite a while five years five years in a
black neighborhood I got in a fight
every other day for it okay but because
I had red hair they called me a rooster
I literally got in fights every day so
you got bullied that's not racism
exactly
discrimination based on what it is
exactly where racism is it's not racism
he wasn't oppressed we were the ones
that oppressed so you can't call that
right how are you oppressed in 2023 how
are you oppressed because I got news for
you honey if you had a skill set that
was worth something to somebody you
would be the richest [__] in here so
say we didn't exist that slavery exists
slavery exists yeah it also it also
existed for Iris I'm not trying to
belittle what happened I would never no
I'm not no I'm not UK talking slavery no
no no no no here's why there was no
slaves here here's why no this is very
important can we stop this is very
important to me I have a lot of young
black men that follow me there's no
[__] way on Earth I'm gonna let them
believe that they have a lesser chance
than anybody else if they just work
their ass off there's no [__] way I'm
not sitting on their dreams like that
I'll be damned you call me a racist if
you want fine but we have to call me a
racist all day I'm not I don't care
there's no way I'm letting those young
men believe that [__] 100 because I know
plenty of black guys look King rich is
here right now is a [__] winner all
day long because he didn't let that [__]
happen we have to work harder
what about all of our friends that are
black that are very very successful
looking at racism is for broke people
I just finally insulting don't it's not
it's not insulting you lead with it get
a new identity
you're so much more than that you're so
much more oh yeah I know then don't lead
with it it's [__] this [__] I
didn't lead with it I use it as a
comparison for me to explain why I'm not
the same as every girl that puts
themselves in one thing they want to
tell us the skills you have and the
person you are that why don't you lead
with that yeah
no
wait wait wait we have to do one at a
time stop just stop stop wait can I say
something it's not a thing where they
hate women if anything they love women
for a man to tell you to think
positively how is that hatred the people
are literally telling us that what we
think is what's going to manifest so
therefore think positive thoughts and
positive things will happen to you you
guys on this table who are talking about
feminism you're all negative because why
would you focus so much on comments why
would you focus so much on who's looking
at your hairstyle your accent or
whatever and then someone comes to tell
you actually focus on the positive and
you guys are saying they hate you no no
but you can't focus on them just the
other day a man applied for a job and
they told him he can't get the job
because of his afraid so you can't tell
us to not focus on it when it is the
focus yes and watch the news it
literally happened the other day yeah
but that's his experience but if he was
smart he's not gonna let that hold him
back that's the whole point from the
news
you can't tell us to not focus on it a
certain places my Afro the first thing
people are going to do is stare at me
and certain places won't want to give me
the job just because
stop wait thank you do you know why you
saw that in the news
because they want you to believe that
racism is a real problem it wasn't even
underneath so you're lying she just said
that it was it was underneath it went
viral on Twitter let's fact check though
I said it was on the news
but you're saying on why you saw it on
the news yeah that's why I saw it so
you're adding to it they share these
stories like George Floyd and like that
afro nonsense that you saw in the news
in order for you to believe that there's
a system that's holding you back it's
not and you saw here we're talking about
race hold on so the man went online and
was like I didn't get the job sat there
and didn't have at this point when he
pick and chose to run that story because
it gives people like you a reason to
feel people like me exactly people like
you know they used to want to give my
mom free food in the market because they
didn't believe that white woman could
have three little kids and have fruits
they used to give her food because it's
the thing that were little African
children that suffer these times we're
quite wealthy so for example okay my
overall point is that people like to
have a victim mindset especially
victimization I'm just saying he exists
okay that's it that's my point is that
we hear this victimized mindset right
now in order to give you a way to
navigate the world that justifies a lot
of your thoughts and beliefs we're
talking about race and you're like it's
giving misogyny
what does calling out the victimization
of the race you feel the vibrations of
misogyny of yeah of your mentality your
mentality is one of you're a type of man
that's what what type of man no sister
they're just here trying to make you
look stupid that's what their job is
that's not that hard it's not that
[__] hard don't take it personal they
literally just want to cut you out I'm
asking I'm trying to get to what she
really believes King Richard's trains me
for this all right what what are the
vibrations that I'm giving you that is
given misogynist why what did we say I'm
not being funny if what what value do
you see and what what how do you value
women do you see the value of women like
like you I explain it five minutes ago
you didn't I said that I'm against
feminism and I said that yeah but if
you're gonna call him a misogynist if
she asked me a question I said the value
of a woman is motherhood and raising
children I said that we respect mothers
I opened the show by saying that okay so
what did I say that makes you think that
I'm a massager that's a serious
allegation
I said it's given misogyny what is
giving massages no vibration my
vibrations you're vibrating misogyny
right now so are you vibrating with
racism too what goes on and we're moving
a little bit mean that's why I'm moving
a little bit now you're trying to put
yourself
and I don't like that that's a bit
misogynistic right yeah
it's the master yeah I can feel it and
it's like you're trying to suppress my
feminine
he's trying to suppress your [__]
like come on bro y'all look y'all all
smart pretty young women you can do
anything you want to in this [__]
world and my message is this Oprah
listen
[__] here's the thing and you swear a
lot I do a lot I'm sorry I do I know I
do I'm gonna keep doing that so here's
the thing I just there's no planet where
I'm gonna allow particularly a young
black man to think that man young white
man yeah go one because
we're talking about race particularly
right now and I like well there's no
planet
do I want to ever put out into the
universe are allowed to be put out in
the universe that a young black man is
going to not be able to be successful in
his life because of his skin color
there's no chance and I will sit here
and and you can call me whatever you
want but I just know too many of them
and I know too many have been successful
yeah but you're one of a few you're not
but like the majority well you have to
understand how many people watch this
show how many people watch her channel
it's important no you're not
it doesn't stop you but it does make a
little challenge
can I he's like he's like you're one of
the first white men that I've met who
have this mentality maybe
you know what I honestly I think most
white people
prejudices exists maybe not racism let's
adjust the word not racism Prejudice is
something different I believe that and I
think that there's Prejudice all over
the world
it's just a little bit stronger negative
countries like lowly sure and in
countries like Japan that are very you
know homogeneous homogeneous they won't
even let you in the restaurant unless
you're Japanese like you guys you think
you've seen racism bro there's some
places in this world I've been that are
turbo racist outwardly and get away with
it I think a black person today has a
better chance than they've ever had is
it completely Fair no I don't think so
but I don't think life is completely
fair at all and there's no way I'm going
to let somebody mentally handicap
themselves from the jump and you know
about me I don't I don't think it's an
impairment to me I know it made me it
made me a bit stronger but I know he
exists and for you it's a superpower
yeah right I just want to reframe it
thank you and have a different
relationship with it but for me
independent woman because she because
she led with it
she said she's leaving yeah but it
didn't sound like a superpower then did
it no because you didn't allow me to
finish she starts I know you're leading
without what does that have to do you
became challenging and this is the
problem this is why she said you guys
are feeling a little bit like misogyny
but that's not what she means
aggressive
they're just talking about pressure
because it's important
it's important because you have to go
out into the world with the absolute
mindset that regardless of your
circumstances regardless of your
background or your racial um ethnicity
or anything that you can go out and you
can make a success of your life we all
have to do that 100 and that's where
they're getting so impassionate about it
you know
foreign
looks like in my opinion Real Love is
dark and Real Love Takes risk so let's
say you're [__] up let's just say it
was racism I'm willing to step in front
of you and have you be angry with me
so I can somehow change where you're
[__] up and you can be mad at me if
you want because most people people
don't give a [__] about you will let you
leave and be like that [__] is [__]
up I would much rather get into a heated
argument with you and have the courage
to sit in front of you and tell you my
truth and have the thought of somebody
thinking that I'm racist on the internet
I'd rather do that than let the young
man that follow me believe they don't
have a shot I'd much rather sit in that
and to me that's the only kind of
friends I want it's people that are
going to tell me the truth when I'm
[__] up so you get mad at me but I
just hate to see it led that way I'd
much rather hear about the skills you
have and and I'm with you Pearl I'll
I'll triple it I'm gonna say Well done
to my skills are you gonna say go [__]
yeah [__] yeah you know how much you
don't deny you know how much women
privilege you have you just gotta offer
it a thousand dollars to see if you
could fix the car that's what I'm saying
it's a superpower should I take it black
because you're a black girl don't take
it back
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible